Hello
Freak bitches.
I'm minding my business.
I ain't bothering nobody.
I'm watching the baby.
It's 4:30 that day about this.
No,
I heard a knock on the door.
Never opened my door.
You getting knocked on my door.
You want.
If you don't follow me,
I don't know.
I just sit there and watch TV.
I'm one of those motherfuckers.
Unless you call me
coming over.
I don't open the door for anybody.
You can and that's.
I've been doing that for 30 years,
right?
Or nothing,
but the baby.
It was like Daddy,
somebody.
Oh my God.
Damn it.
I opened the door.
Three women at my door,
two of them are cockeyed.
I swear to God.
I'm not even gonna be funny there from the Cert Church of Latter Day saints.
Okay,
how you doing?
I go,
listen,
I'm not into this stuff,
but my wife is.
My wife is ended up more as I just said that so I could get off the hook.
I'm feeling the baby.
If you want to come back in 30 minutes ago because I'm really thirsty.
Can I get a glass of water or a water bottle?
You don't want man,
that's how they get you in.
That's a tactic.
I close the fucking door,
man.
I don't give a fuck.
Hold on one second.
I close the door.
My wife is from Tennessee.
She saves those fucking bottles and fills up with water and takes them through
yoga.
I throw them away.
What are we?
White trash.
I throw these things away.
Once that done,
that done,
my wife says him and puts them in the freezer for headaches and shit,
so I wanted to get one of those and there was no bottles,
so I give her a glass of water.
She takes off.
Now I'm running against the clock.
These three little more than bitches are going to come back.
My wife walks in and let me go outside and get an,
you know they stole my pipe.
When they asked me to get the water,
they stole my pot pipe from the balcony.
Nobody else was on that balcony.
The water got comes on that balcony and he sees the pipe.
I don't leave without that.
I'm not that stupid.
I just lead the pipe cleaner.
The pipe,
the fucking.
My wife was there and one came,
the lady who takes care of mercy,
they didn't steal a fucking.
The Mormons stole my pipe.
Let me tell you something.
I got in that car and hunted those three little cock eyed bitches down all over.
I couldn't find them.
They never came back.
They stole my pot pipe.
Do you think they stole it because they were just stealing things or do you
think they stole it because they didn't want you to be engaging in such horrible
behavior?
Smoking marijuana when you're taking care of your child.
I wasn't smoking when I was taking care of the child.
I just always leave it out there.
It's always.
That's how I mean.
I mean like you have one,
you have a child,
but he's still smoking marijuana.
Like how dare you?
What are you doing with a pot pipe out.
We need to take this from him.
Maybe they took it,
but if they smoked and cocked,
know that two bitches ain't shit that had holes in her feet and the shoes on
what religion.
Since people are knocking on doors,
I'm memorial day that's guaranteed.
Slammed the door to the face.
Then you have another one that you kept.
He kept coming back.
Yeah,
I had a job or witness.
I was stringing him out.
Made a bad time to come back in an hour and see him lurking in front of my
house.
I couldn't even go home.
I couldn't even go behind him and strung out for like four months though.
Every time he'd come over,
you know what I really want to talk to you.
Give me those pamphlets.
I called the number you would think maybe starting from your basic know your
zero set point of just,
you know,
now we're going to reboot civilization.
Um,
you would think that if you had this kind of process,
each candidate would be more impressive than the next man.
You'd be like,
I can't believe each.
Each person who came to the podium,
like,
yeah,
it'd be like,
it'd be like the dunk contest,
you know,
for the NBA.
I'd be like,
oh my God,
I could just.
When you thought you saw the best dunk in your life,
you know,
the next guy comes along.
And it would be that.
It would be that on every topic,
right?
It'd be like you'd be talking about the science of climate change.
You'd be talking about the actual dynamics of the war on terror,
so topics that seem to have no relationship where you would have to be.
You'd be amazed that anyone could be an expert in all of them.
You would find someone who is an expert,
a functional expert in all of them.
Pretty winter,
dude.
Yeah.
But,
and,
but someone who is also ethically wise who does wasn't just,
wasn't obviously an asshole.
Um,
and who,
who,
who had a,
a mature relationship to change in his or her mind.
Right?
So like this whole bit about flip flopping and,
and not,
um,
you know,
being someone who could honestly represent changes of mind in,
in,
across a political career.
Right?
You know,
it's nowhere written.
That is a good thing to believe today,
what you believe 20 years ago.
In fact,
if you do that on every topic,
it means basically you haven't been in dialogue with the world.
Um,
but there's something,
it's so taboo to change your mind that either you have to lie about it or you
have to pretend it was a,
it was always that way,
or um,
it's just a,
a,
I'm an assistant,
yet the system is,
is broken in that respect,
but given the choices,
you know,
and when you have a choice between someone who is for all her flaws,
been in the game for long enough to be really well informed and capable of
compromise and capable of,
uh,
not just,
just
breaking
the entire machine and you have someone who's just,
he could just kinda stepped off the set of his reality TV show and then a lied
about everything and,
uh,
and elbowed his way onto your television set and never left because,
you know,
CNN couldn't figure out how to give the mic to someone else.
Um,
it's a,
it's amazing.
Well,
he's a product of attention because they realized that there's a heated race,
right?
The heated race.
This guy was really famous and in a heated race,
this guy would say some crazy stuff and so they would tune into um,
so everybody had to do an intro.
So because of him saying crazy stuff,
he accelerated the amount they were talking about them.
So they're constantly talking about him and barely talking about other people
and,
but he's created a worm hole in our political process now where there's nothing
so crazy that could disqualify him among the people who like him to.
So he can just keep it just like nuclear bombs of craziness that the press can't
ignore that the,
every time they think,
okay,
this is the crazy thing he said that's going to harm his candidacy,
so let's shine a light on it.
It just helps him,
you know,
he could just,
he could,
he could.
He didn't get on twitter right now and say,
you know who I'd like to fuck.
I'd like to Nicki Minaj
and,
and it would work for him.
It would work for them.
You would see a use a tweet storm of a billion people who say,
I'd like to fuck Nikki Minaj to go get her
and it's insanity.
That's where we are.
Did you ever do a program thing?
Did you go to an alcoholics anonymous meeting or just stop now?
I had a son so I had,
there were a couple of times I was like,
alright,
I need to,
I need to quit and quit and that never works.
And then there was one night where,
so it's,
it's the first real time on the road.
I was terrible with women in high school and college and then suddenly I hit the
road as a comic and they're everywhere and they're interested and life is
different.
And so there was a show.
I was doing a show first already and usually the sororities that sponsor comedy
shows or like the philanthropy sorority and they're all terrible.
Uh,
no,
these girls were all hot.
Just just dimes.
The whole chapter just full.
They had like one ugly friend is as the charity,
but they had just gorgeous girls and my opener goes up and bombs and then I go
up to a standing room only crowd and crush and so now it's afterward we're
hanging out.
There's like this after party thing that they put together for just them and the
two of us,
one of which they hated because he bombed and the like,
there are just these eight hot girls surrounding me.
One shoulder,
another one out of the way to sit next to me.
I was like,
this is,
this is like nothing I've ever experienced.
And then they took us to another party and I'm pretty sure someone put something
in my drink.
Not In the way of like I want to fuck this guy in the way of like,
this is a guy getting all the attention away from the other guys.
And I think one of the other guys fucked with my drink.
Real.
Yeah.
Because I got super violently ill very quickly,
like very,
very quickly and I spent the whole night I was supposed to stay at the sorority
house.
Like I,
the plan was I was going to stay in the guest room so I didn't even have to do
the whole excuse of like,
Hey,
can I use your bathroom?
Can I come in for like,
I just,
I was supposed to go back there with them and I spent the entire night just,
just vomiting.
It was terrible.
Wow.
Somebody spiked your drink and then I lost a Gig the next day and at the time
it's my first year on the road.
I lost a $1,500 gig the next day because you were so sick.
I couldn't do it.
I was,
we were driving,
it was the middle of winter,
but I was wearing two pairs of pants,
two sweatshirts and in a sleeping bag in the car with the heat on full blast and
I was shivering the whole way.
Like I was fucked up
so that you didn't have the flu or something.
That sounds like the flu.
It went away like six hours later.
So it could've been,
it could've been a very temporary.
Flew a well timed flu.
I don't know,
but that was the night where I was just like,
I can't keep doing this.
Have you ever heard of a drug that does that?
Like a drug.